FLORIDA THOSE ARE YOUR HEADLINES
ON TO YOU,.
BRIAN: BRIAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ACCUSING PEOPLE OF
USING RACIST LANGUAGE FOR
CALLING THE UP CREASE OF
MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER WHAT IT
IS, WHICH IS A SURGE.
>> ANYONE WHO IS USING THE TERM
SURGE AROUND YOU CONSCIENCELY IS
TRYING TO INVOKE A MILITARISTIC
FRAME.
THIS IS NOT A SURGE.
THESE ARE CHILDREN AND THEY ARE
NOT INSURGENTS AND WE ARE NOT
BEING INVADED, WHICH BY THE WAY,
IS A WHITE SUPREMACIST IDEA,
PHILOSOPHY.
BRIAN: OUR NEXT GUEST HAS SEEN
THE SURGE WITH HIS OWN EYES AND
SAYS THE CONGRESSWOMAN IS WRONG.
REALLY?
SENIOR WRITER FOR TOWN HALL.COM
JULIO ROW HAS JOINS US NOW.
JULIO, IS THAT WHITE SUPREMACIST
LANGUAGE THE WORD SURGE.
>> I’M NOT A WHITE SUPREMACIST I
HAVE BROWN SKIN OVER HERE.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY NOT A SURGE AND
NOT RACIST TO CALL IT THAT.
THE NUMBER THAT I SAW JUST ALL
LAST WEEK IS ABSOLUTELY
STAGGERING AND THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE ILLEGALLY
CROSSING AND TURNING THEMSELVES
OVER TO BORDER PATROL.
AND, YES, I’M WELL AWARE THAT
THERE ARE KIDS THERE, AGAIN, I
WAS THERE FIRST HAND AND SEEN
THEM AND OFTEN THEY WERE BY
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS A SURGE ONE OF THE THING
DISTURBING ABOUT IT HAPPENING A
LOT SOONER THAN WHEN THE SURGES
TYPICALLY HAPPEN IS AROUND APRIL
AND MAY.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE
APPREHENSION NUMBERS ARE BUT
THERE ARE STEMS WE ARE GOING TO
BE OVER 150,000 APPREHENSIONS,
OF COURSE, THAT’S JUST THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WANTED,
FOR THE MOST PART, WANTED TO BE
CAUGHT.
BRIAN: RIGHT, WE SEE HOW CLOSE
THESE COTS ARE TOGETHER.
WE SEE HOW THESE YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE RIGHT NOW RIGHT ON TOP OF
EACH OTHER.
WE KNOW WE ARE IN A PANDEMIC.
WE DID NOT HAVE TO ALLOW
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS TO STAY.
WE WERE FLYING THEM BACK.
JOE BIDEN CHANGED THAT AS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT, AOC, WHO IS A SPIRITUAL
LEADER OF THE LEFT HAS -- HAD A
DIFFERENT TONE IN 2019 WHEN
THINGS WEREN’T EVEN AS BAD AS
THEY ARE NOW.
LISTEN.
>> NO CHILD SHOULD EVER BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
NO CHILD SHOULD EVER BE TAKEN
FROM THEIR FAMILY.
NO WOMAN SHOULD EVER BE LOCKED
UP IN A PEN WHEN THEY HAVE DONE
NO HARM TO A HUMAN BEING.
THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN WATER.
THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN BASIC
ACCESS TO HUMAN RIGHTS.
BRIAN: SHE MADE UP THE LAST
LAWFULLASTHALF AS PEOPLE WERE DR
OF TOILET BOWLS.
THIS IS WORSE AND HER TONE HAS
CHANGED.
DID IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> NO.
NOT AT ALL.
AND, REALLY, CONGRESSWOMAN IS
NOT ALONE IN THIS BUT SHE REALLY
IS THE PRIME EXAMPLE OF
DEMOCRATS AND SOME PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA CLAIMING THAT THEY WERE,
YOU KNOW, THEY CARE ABOUT THESE
MIGRANTS, CARE ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS THEY WERE WHEN N.
WHEN IT WAS UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND NOW OBVIOUSLY THEIR
TUNE HAS CHANGED BECAUSE THIS IS
NOW A DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION.
LOOK, IT’S NOT LIKE SHE DOESN’T
KNOW WHERE TEXAS IS.
SHE WAS JUST IN THE STATE RIGHT
AFTER THE WINTER STORMS THAT
PASSED BY THROUGH.
AND SO SHE KNOWS WHERE THE STATE
IS.
AND SHE KNOWS WHERE THESE
FACILITIES ARE AND, YET, SHE
HASN’T MADE THE EFFORT TO COME
DOWN HERE.
LIKE I SAID, SHE IS NOT ALONE IN
THIS.
THE HYPOCRISY IS ABSOLUTELY
ASTOUNDING.
BRIAN: THAT’S WHY YOU GIVE
CONGRESSMAN CUELLAR OTHER
DEMOCRATIC MAYORS I JUST WANT TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
SHE DID COME OUT YESTERDAY AND
SAY THIS IS INHUMANE
UNACCEPTABLE HORRIBLE CONDITIONS
OF CHILDREN IN CBP’S CUSTODY.
IT’S NOT CBP’S PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM IS THE POLICIES THAT
SEND THESE KIDS HERE.
RIGHT NOW THERE IS OVER 18,000.
ARE YOU GOING BACK?
REAL QUICK.
>> I SUSPECT I WILL BE GOING
BACK SHORTLY BECAUSE THIS IS A
CRISIS AND THERE IS A SURGE.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
THERE IS NO END TO IT EVEN IF